Come in and have a look at this top secret
project we've been working on.
It's finally time to push the button and put
the MIGHTY SHRINK LAZORRR to the test!
I’m ready.
We did it!
It worked.
Right under our noses there is so much hidden
that we never get to see with our own eyes
– entire realms of bizarre structures and
outlandish creatures.
What a magical place this is.
A forest of slime molds, single-celled organisms
that work together and form fungus-like structures.
But we don't have time to hang out with these
calm fellows any longer.
Psssst!
Now we’re in the kingdom of the mighty tardigrades
– don’t disturb them in their death-like
slumber.
Don’t worry though, they will wake up once
the conditions are less rough.
Oof, didn’t mean to get in the way!
Your cells are hustling to keep you alive,
coordinating myriads of proteins.
This might be the weirdest place yet, with
no up or down.
There’s way too much going on – better
move on.
Now we are inside one of the parts that allow
you to watch this video.
The structure of a microchip is so small,
it nearly breaks the rules of the quantum
realm.
– Wait, something is happening!
These hidden worlds are all part of our 12,023
Human Era Calendar.
This time you can join us on a journey through
the microcosm.
With each turn of the page you will reveal
a new world you didn’t know existed right
beneath your feet.
You know the drill by now: as always it’s
a super high-quality calendar, very shiny
and only available for a short time.
We also have a few special deals for you in
our shop.
The calendar is a true piece of kurzgesagt
you can take home with you.
And we say this every year but it’s true:
every calendar purchase directly supports
what we do here at kurzgesagt.
And that’s not just creating videos but
sparking curiosity all around the world.
So because of you, we can spread knowledge
and ignite an appreciation for space, nature
and life in people everywhere.
Thank you so much for making this possible!
Have a wonderful 12,023!
See you down in January!